there were
a lot of
guys certainly worthy of consideration
in the eastern conference i think like
you know i think the east was to
probably i think lamellar ball and ma
and miles
charlotte those both of those guys were
having hell of a year jared allen i mean
when the last time we said the hornets
are going to be a lock for the playoffs
possibly right so that's that that was
uh impressive the same way darius has
done for cleveland those guys
have done for uh charlotte so you know
but i don't think you could you know you
can't argue
oh no
i'm just saying those those are your
seven reserves out of out of a field
that has a lot of worthy candidates for
all-star consideration what do you think
dre
i think uh i think miles and lamello may
have split votes i was actually looking
at the eastern conference standards the
other day
and i'm like i i feel like both of them
have has had all-star years but then you
look up and they're either seventh or
eighth place in the eastern conference
and which the records in the eastern
conference aren't that strong and so
when i saw that i was like i don't think
they'll get both in but they'll get one
but i'm actually shocked that neither
one of them got in and
it's probably because they split votes
yeah they are the number seven team in
the east at 28 and 24.
um
but charlotte shut out of all star
consideration there
let's take a look at who we thought
might be selected uh on this night by
the coaches
um
let's see
tyler hero was certainly somebody you
thought might guess
to me he's the glaring weakness weakness
yeah uh he's the guy
he's the guy to me who should have been
on the loose color hero's been great all
year and no hey no disrespect to jimmy
butler
if i had to pick one guy for heat it'd
be tyle a hero
well you did no i'm coming forward no
you did he's i know i'm just saying he
to me he'll be saying who got left out
my bridges he got an argument but tyler
hero in my opinion i think the butler
the only thing that made me kind of move
away not because he's not an all-star
and didn't have an all-star year i just
thought the game's missed and so i was
like oh you missed that many games so if
i have to choose one i would probably
possibly go a hero but jimmy butler
if you put the body of work of what he's
done while he's been on the floor it's
been well tyler hero's been great all
year he's the sixth man of the year
easily it may be that early on
made 10 starts in his 43 games and i
know we're playing positionless
basketball but
when you announce the team chuck said
something very important small i would
like to see at least one big guy nearest
a bonus you know he's been you know
playing playing very very well this year
i would like to see him get in there
because they are a small chuck yeah
and if you're going to take no listen
this is all just i actually agree with
you ernie uh if i had to pick another
guy a big guy it would be jared allen
i mean because he to me he is fantastic
he's the leader of that team and him and
garland together man and then
you factor in mobley but jared allen to
me has been that the guy in cleveland
they're 16 or 11.
i think this year
yeah i i actually like that organization
i grew up in the midwest watching
jermaine o'neill and those guys so i'm a
big fan of the organization but they
stink this year i actually didn't think
sabonis had a chance at all yeah they're
not he's a great player but not this
year yeah 19 and 34 and number 13 in the
east um i think that's kind of a
dejante murray kind of situation too
dejante murray putting up really good
all-star worthy numbers for a team
that's struggling on the record side